- Man, when you look at the numbers,
they're very, very clear.
In 2019, and we'll go to 2020 so far,
but in 2019, there were nine
African-American people shot
who were unarmed.
Most people can put two and
two together and realize that
just because you're unarmed,
don't mean you're not a threat,
don't mean that it's unjustified.
But for the sake of arguing,
just say that all nine unarmed black males
were killed by police unjustifiably.
There is 44 million black people.
I have lost count of the
zeros and the percentage
of you getting killed by a
police officer unjustifiably.
And when you look at those numbers,
and then you go and you look
at the amount of black people
who get killed on a day
to day basis through black
on black violence, and you
do not see the same level
of outrage, the same level of protest,
we can clearly see that it's
some brainwashing going on.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is the Rubin Report.
Reminder everybody, to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
and click that notification bell.
And joining me today
is an ex police officer
and Co-founder of the BLEXIT
Movement, Brandon Tatum.
Welcome back to the Rubin report.
- How you doing, Dave?
Man, good to see you again (laughs)
- I'm good, I'm good.
Thanks for joining us.
I know this is last minute
and you are stretched
a million ways because of
everything going on right now.
So, for the people that don't know you,
we're gonna link to our
original interview down below,
but can you just do like a couple minute,
Brandon Tatum 101 by your childhood,
and what got you into policing
and then out of policing.
And then we're gonna obviously
talk about everything
going on right now.
- Okay, cool.
I grew up in Fort Worth, Texas.
I grew up in a split home.
Mom and daddy weren't together,
and they didn't even know their parents
or at least their fathers.
And so people would project that
I would have a certain outcome in life.
Maybe I wouldn't be successful,
but see that wasn't true.
God had a plan for me,
even though my parents were fostering me
to be the best that they could do,
I ended up getting
arrested at eight years old
for smoking marijuana in a vacant house.
And my dad had a very stern
and strong conversation
with me after that incident,
which led me to wanna get
into sports and wanna do the right thing.
From that point, moving forward,
all American football player,
I played college football at
the University of Arizona.
And after the NFL didn't work
out for me, I needed a job.
I needed a career.
I never thought about
being a police officer
a day in my life.
And I signed up 'cause
I needed some money.
I needed a good career.
And I did a ride along
with the Police Department
'cause I had to figure out what the heck
am I gonna actually do, if they hire me?
And after I did a ride
along, it just blew me away.
I was inspired, for the
first time in my life,
I saw a hero and officer Sean Payne
who took me on that ride along.
I started to get into
politics later in my career
as a Police Officer.
And that just led me to where I'm at now.
Now I'm doing things on my
own, on my own business,
working with Candace Owens.
We co-founded BLEXIT.
And now I'm on Dave Rubin
for the second time.
- (laughs) Can you talk
a little bit about how,
when you were a Police Officer
that you sort of knew
how to speak the language
of the people in these communities?
So you were a bridge
between the communities
that were being policed or that
needed the policing the most
and the actual police officers,
because I think that'll
probably be a good segue to
get us to everything else
happening right now.
- Yeah 'cause I grew up
with a lot of exposure
to a lot of things that I
dealt with as a Police Officer
in these communities.
I didn't grow up in a peachy household.
My mom and dad were
separated, like I said before.
And my stepdad was a gang banger
and he used to use drugs
and he ended up dying
from a heroin overdose.
So some of the problems that we dealt with
in the city, I was exposed to them myself.
And so I could speak to
individuals and for some reason,
and I don't know why, 'cause
you're still gonna go to jail
the same way.
But because I was black, a
lot of African-American people
in the communities that I patrolled,
they saw I guess a connection with me.
And so I was able to
be sort of the liaison
or a lack of better terms,
the black person whisper.
They used to always get me
to come to the scene to talk
and to calm down individuals.
And like I said, because
I've been there done that
I was able to communicate effectively.
- Okay, so as I said earlier,
we're gonna link down
to the other interview that we did
so people can get more of your story,
but let's jump into the current situation.
So first off, let's talk
about the incident itself
and the video that now everybody has seen
and has millions and millions
and millions of views.
What happened to George Floyd?
From your outsider perspective,
just knowing the amount
that we can know from
video, what went wrong?
Did anything go right?
What were the other officers doing?
What are you supposed to do as an officer
in a situation like that?
Just lay it all out.
- Yeah, if we had a
training video to show you
what not to do as a police officer
and what not to do as responding officers,
this would probably be a perfect example.
I don't see, or I don't
have any information
of what happened before
this gentleman ended up
on the ground.
But what I can tell you
as a police officer,
a former police officer,
is that it's unacceptable
to have your knee on a man's
neck for, I don't know,
eight, nine minutes.
There's no reason, he's handcuffed.
He's on the ground.
You have leverage over him
and he's complaining of
having medical issues.
People are recording you, and
you still remain in a position
that seems to be putting this gentleman
at a life and death situation.
So as a former police
officer, any rational person,
you should be rendering aid,
you should back off of the guy.
And there was a concept
that I said in a video
that I made on my YouTube channel
is a concept of excited delirium.
And a lot of people never heard
of the concept of excited delirium.
Maybe, if you're not in law enforcement,
you probably will never hear of it.
But excited delirium is
a theory that when people
are hyped up on drugs,
those uppers like PCP, methamphetamine,
it gets your heart rate up,
gets your adrenaline rushing,
and what happens you become a superhuman,
and then your body begin to crash.
So you go down a path of
crashing, like if you drink sugar
and you get tired or sleepy afterwards,
but this crash, it goes and
it continues until you die.
And we're trained as police officers
to be able to observe that.
And some of what Mr. George
Floyd was experiencing
seemed to be a level of excited delirium.
So when a guy is going down like that,
a police officer should
back off, render aid,
roll him on his side,
make sure he can breathe
because he could be hyperventilating.
He could be having some
distress that may not be
a direct connection with
your knee on his neck.
And you should know that
as a police officer.
- So it seems to me that
part of the reaction
to this one that is totally justified
is that the officer had
his hand in his pocket
almost as if, I'm not even trying here,
I can just do whatever I want.
What do you think?
And I know you can't read their minds,
but the other three officers
that are standing there,
what do you think is
going on in their minds
as they're watching this?
Everyone's laying blame
where it should be lamed
at the officer who did this,
but what about the other guys?
Because that gets to, when
people start talking about
the culture of policing.
- Yeah, I don't think it's so
much of a cultural response.
It's of a human nature.
The other officers I'm
assuming are waiting
for the next officer to say something
and nobody ever says anything.
And then I believe that that
officer seems to be somewhat
of the lead officer on the case.
He's the most I guess, it
could be the most experienced,
he's the most dominant.
And so I'm assuming, and
I don't know if this is
what they were thinking, but
I've seen this happen before
is once operational
momentum gets underway,
there are officers who are assuming
and hoping to God that
the officer with his knee
on the guy's neck is acting in good faith
and it's not gonna kill the
guy and get everybody fired.
So there's a little bit
of expecting the officers
to all do their own job,
and expecting the officer
who was coming across as the leader
to not kill a man in cold blood.
So I think that there's
a little bit of cowardice
that goes on and people in general,
and I see some of that could
have probably spilled over
to this law enforcement
experience with George Floyd.
- When you see that video,
do you immediately view it
through a racial lens?
You know the way the media
pushes everything on us
is that we have to see this
as white officer, black man that we have
to view it purely through that.
And I'm not saying we shouldn't
see it through that lens,
but there are several lenses
that we should see these things.
When you see that, how
much of your reaction to it
is just viewed through
the racial prism alone?
- Well, Dave, I'd never
look at things racially
unless I have a reason to.
So when I looked at this
video, I see what I believe
to be cop or police misconduct.
And I see a man struggling for his life,
or potentially having a medical issue
with no officers rendering aid.
Race never entered into
my mind, not one time.
And unless I saw that the
officer was a clans member,
or he came out and said
he hate black people
or something of that nature
that would have instigated me
to have that thought process.
I don't even go down that
road because it's pointless,
it's counterproductive, and
all it does is create division.
And we can never get to a
solution anywhere anyhow,
because some of the officers,
I think it was only one
officer that was white.
And that was the officer
that was using force.
But the other officers are gonna
be held accountable as well.
They all got fired, and
they were other racist.
So to project and make it as
it's a black and white racial
tension thing is disingenuous,
and it's hurtful to the narrative.
And it's hurtful to us
actually getting justice
where justice is deserved.
- Okay, so since I think everyone watching
this probably agrees with that.
I mean, any sensible person,
we want justice to be served.
Obviously they've been taken into custody
and hopefully the system will
deal with them appropriately.
So we have to shift to now what's becoming
the bigger story here.
So as the guy that co-founded
BLEXIT with Candace Owens.
It seems to me that you guys have made
just absolutely staggering
amounts of traction
in terms of waking up black people too.
You don't have to be a Democrat,
which is just a simple fact
of the world.
Your skin color of
course should not dictate
what political party you are.
So first, let's just start with that.
How is that just connected to all of this?
The narrative that we're seeing right now
that America is racist and
that policing is racist,
and it's systemic and that
our founding is racist.
How is all of that stuff
connected to why you guys wanted
to start BLEXIT?
- Yeah, because when you
think about it for what it is,
it's like we are outraged.
We are burning down communities,
protesting and rioting day
in and day out for what?
And what I have observed
and Candace alike,
what we have observed is
that we have been brainwashed
into thinking with our emotions
and not thinking with facts.
Man, when you look at the
numbers, they're very, very clear.
In 2019, and we'll go to 2020 so far,
but in 2019, there were
nine African-American people
shot who were unarmed.
Most people can put two and two together
and realize that just
because you're unarmed,
don't mean you're not a threat,
don't mean that it's unjustified.
But for the sake of arguing,
just say that all unarmed black males
were killed by police unjustifiably.
There is 44 million black people.
I have lost count of the zeros
and the percentage of you getting killed
by a police officer unjustifiably.
And when you look at those numbers,
and then you go and you look
at the amount of black people
who get killed on a day to day basis
through black on black violence,
and you do not see the
same level of outrage,
the same level of protest,
we can clearly see that
it's some brainwashing going on.
And what Candace and I want to do
is just outfit people with the truth,
and give them an outlet to say,
I don't have to just think and be ignorant
just because I'm black.
I can have an open mind.
I can see what's really going on.
Some of these people live in the hood.
Some of the people know
that they're not afraid
of the police.
They know that they're
afraid of gang violence
and abuse that happens in the inner city.
A lot of people know that
it has something to do
with social economic status
and not just necessarily
the color of your skin.
So we are pushing truth.
And initially it hurts, man.
A lot of people hate us initially.
They don't wanna hear from us
with Coon sellout uncle Tom's,
but as time goes along
and they can see that
there's a BS narrative being pushed.
They can see that black people
are destroying their own communities,
that it has gotten out of control.
They begin to see people
like myself and Candace
who are promoting facts
and they begin to wake up.
It's simple mathematics.
- So I got to bring up a
guy who I know, you know,
and I know you saw this moment
when Larry Elder beat
me senseless with fact
- (Brandon laughs)
and woke me up.
- Woke me up to so much
of this stuff, right?
But what do you do with
a certain set of people
who don't respond to facts?
Because even on Twitter
for the last 24 hours,
I tried to take the weekend off
and it didn't work that well,
but just in the last 24 hours
of being on Twitter, I
see the type of stuff
that you are putting out there.
I see the type of stuff
that a lot of conservatives
are putting out there
relative to facts and numbers
and all of these things.
And I never see any counter
to those things generally
by people on the left.
I see the sort of overly
emotional, we are racist because
in and of itself, it is true.
It's self evident that
we're a racist nation.
So what do you do when
a certain set of people
won't accept facts?
- Well, I go with the Bible, man.
I mean, Jesus was
preaching truth and facts
and they killed him.
And so my thing is that
we need to just continue
to promote facts and truth,
and understand that
we're a planting seeds.
Not every single person
is gonna turn around
every time we open our
mouth and say something,
but we have to be consistent
with what we know to be true.
Just like Jesus, even
though they killed him,
he was raised on the third day,
and now he's the most talked
about person ever in history.
The Bible is the most sold book
in the history of the world.
So we have to continue to
stick with the mission,
keep promoting facts
and understand that we're planting seeds,
and at some point those
seeds will be watered.
And one of the reasons why we can do that
is because Candace and I are a product
of seeds being planted.
Like you said, Larry Elder and
others planted seeds in us.
And then in 2016, the
perfect storm of enough water
and sunshine sprouted
up seeds that are now
some of the most impactful individuals
in the black movement.
- No, I mean, it's been
unbelievable just to see
this thing grow.
I tweeted out about a
year ago in the midst
of one of these stories
that Trump's gonna get
something like 30% of the black vote.
And of course, nobody wants
to be in the prediction game.
And I had a lot of blue check
lefties really angry at me
for saying it.
And of course everything right now.
It's like, "Who the hell
knows what's gonna happen."
But I think you guys have made a dent
and whether that dent is fully evident
in this coming election,
or if it's the one after
or the one after, it just seems obvious.
But let's move to sort of
the immediacy right now,
because it seems to me,
this is no longer about George Floyd.
I mean, when you're watching
people burn down stores,
break into liquor shops,
loot the Nike store,
tear down a Target, all of the rest of it.
What do you think the transition
is from a righteous cause
of not wanting to see
someone be killed unjustly
to where we're at right now?
Like how many steps does that take?
And do you think some
of this was preplanned
before it all began just
a couple of days ago?
- Yeah, man, I think it's a
lot of people in our society
that are just disgruntled.
There's a lot of people
who didn't get parent well.
that just want violence.
They don't want justice.
They want revenge.
They have been brainwashed.
They don't wanna go to work.
They don't wanna work hard.
They don't believe in the American dream.
They hate this country,
they hate themselves.
And those people tend to flare up
when we have incidents like this,
because clearly, they are
not focused on Georgia Floyd.
They're not focused on police brutality.
Police brutality has nothing
to do with Footlocker
and Louis Vuitton and Gucci.
It has nothing to do with stealing
and burning down historical buildings.
Has nothing to do with that.
The man was arrested.
It should be over, the
protest should be over,
the looting, the rioting, the
outrage should be done with,
but it's not.
So we need to understand
that there is a difference
between individuals who are actually
wanting something to change,
and then the individuals
who are burning stuff down
because they're are brats
and they're just menace to society.
And those two parties end up clashing
because politicians and other liberal,
and I'll say, leftist black
talking heads, won't be honest.
They're coming out
saying that it's Antifa,
and they're just completely forgetting
or trying to evade the fact that
there are Black Lives
Matter individuals involved
in this as well.
So we need to take a tough
stance in law enforcement.
We need to start using
force against individuals
who are out here,
burning people's property
and putting people's lives at danger.
And then we also need to have the rhetoric
from President Trump and
other quality leaders
who are saying enough is enough.
We're gonna deal with police brutality,
but this is not the way to do it.
- You mentioned the political leaders
and it's like, well,
Minnesota and Minneapolis,
everyone involved, every
public official is a Democrat.
Every public official is a Democrat.
This thing has nothing to do with Trump.
Doesn't mean that Trump's
reaction has been perfect.
That's a separate issue.
But every time this happens
in one of these cities,
in Atlanta, in Ferguson,
wherever it might be,
we find out that they're
Democrat run cities.
So to that end, or when you
hear DeBlasio in New York city,
he lets criminals out of
jail and then tells them
that if you jump turnstiles,
you won't even get a citation
or anything like that.
Do you think in many ways
the ship has already sailed?
Like how can they reset it?
I've talked to some people at the NYPD
over the last couple of months,
they've had it with the leadership,
but I think they don't
exactly know what to do
because they are civil servants still,
but they know that their
leaders are not allowing them
to restore law and order.
- Yeah, I think the
citizens are waking up, man.
Even with the co COVID
epidemic and all that going on,
you can see, most of the liberal mayors,
the liberal governors,
they want people to shut down forever.
They don't want you to ever work again.
They wanna destroy your businesses.
And people were able
to see that with COVID.
And now you look at the cities
that are getting burned down.
These liberal mayors and governors
won't even contest these individuals.
People's businesses are
getting burned to the ground.
They're never coming back.
The reputation of the city
is completely tarnished.
They're willing to put you in
jail for not wearing a mask
or not social distancing,
but they're letting people
go have a free for all.
And I'll tell you this,
the governor of Minnesota
came out and literally poked the bear
at the black community.
Was making statements about,
"How, oh, this is unjust."
And everything like that
got people riled up.
And then when it hit the fan,
they're not here to protect the citizens,
the law abiding citizens.
So people are watching this
unfold and that's why myself,
you, others, Candace Owens, Larry Elder,
a lot of other people that I
know who are focused on facts
are able to wake these people up.
I get so many messages a day
saying, "Thank God you exist.
"Thank God, I never
thought of this before."
But we are here to wake
people up to the truth.
Not Democrat, not Republican,
not black, not white,
but waking people up to the
truth of what's going on.
And the citizens will turn first,
and that's when everything will unravel
and we'll have justice
and we'll have equality,
I think, outside of this
Democratic run situation.
- So speaking of the
Democratic run situation,
last time we did this, you
were here in my studio,
in my home here in Los Angeles.
So right now I was just scanning Twitter
before I started chatting with you.
And I can see activists
Antifa and Black Lives Matter
activists talking about
which neighborhoods
to go to depending on whether
they have immigrants there,
or it's more heavily black
or more heavily white
or the rest of it.
What should law enforcement
be doing right now?
I mean, we know as seven
o'clock rolls around
and it gets darker, even
if there's a curfew,
we know what's gonna most
likely happen tonight.
It's gonna be the same thing
that happened last night.
What should they be doing?
If you're an officer
or you're the head of the LAPD,
what should you be doing right now?
- It's time to take a strong stance.
I said this on the news earlier,
or it was a couple of days
ago that America is acting
like a parent with a kid
that's out of control,
and you just let them run wild.
You already talked to him.
You already put him in timeout.
Now it's time to get a whipping.
We've already told them they need to stop.
People have been arrested.
If you keep doing this,
you're gonna have to be
met with force.
And if I was the head of LAPD
or any chief in any one of these cities,
you have to be met with force.
You're not gonna damage property.
People are paying tax dollars
for police to protect property
and protect life.
You come out here and you
try to burn down buildings.
You're gonna get met with force,
and all the way from minimal
force, taser, pepper ball,
bean bag gun, all the way to deadly force.
If we do that force continuum,
I guarantee you people
will not be stealing from Louis Vuitton
and going through the
city, ravishing the city,
tearing up homeless
camps, it will not happen.
The Police Department has to be strong.
You keep taking a weak stance,
they're gonna take advantage of us.
- It is part of the fear
there that the police officers
or the administrators, whoever
the mayor, whoever it is,
they know that if they take that strong,
let's say tonight, they were like,
"All right, we're taking the
stronger stance tonight."
They know that causes a spike
that then causes the media
to go more crazy, that then
instigates a new wave of it.
That in many ways, their
acquiescence is exactly
what has led to this situation
that now seems like violence
is the only thing that's gonna end it.
- Yeah, and I get that.
I understand.
I mean, we had to have these conversations
at the University of Arizona
when I was a police in Tucson,
because after they win the final four
and they wanna protest
and burn down the city.
So we've had these conversations
before, but like I said,
I keep liking it to a child.
If you keep just pandering
and saying, "Oh, I don't wanna
"spank in a day.
"It's just gonna make you more upset."
You gotta be strong first
and they'll react to it.
There's gonna be some fall out.
There may be a couple of
people that lose their lives,
but at some point we have
to take a strong stance
as a country, as a law enforcement agency
so we can be respected.
People are gonna hate
police, no matter what.
And this is one problem that
I have sometimes with Trump
and sometimes I have with the
Republican administration,
is that stop worrying about
what people who hate you
are gonna think about you.
They're gonna hate you, if you do nothing,
they're gonna hate you, if
you take a strong stance,
they're gonna hate you, if you're right.
So just do what's right
and don't worry about
what the naysayers say.
- Did you happen to
catch Van Jones' comment
in the last couple of days where he said,
"What America has to fear more
"is the white Hillary voting liberals."
Did you catch that by chance?
- Yeah, I saw a clip of that,
which is one of the many
things he said (laughs)
- Yeah, so what do you make
of just the general concept
there of that much of this
is sort of guilty, white liberals.
And now I know we're not
identity politics guys
so of course I'm not condoning
everything he's saying.
And I don't think you can
lump white people together
the same way you can't
lump black people together.
But the general idea
let's remove color even,
that it's sort of the guilty liberals
who in many ways feed the fire
that then ends up destroying
black communities.
- Yeah, it's the guilty liberals
that are white and black
because you have all these black leaders
pushing the same agenda.
You have white leaders
I mean, listen, the liberal mindset.
Honestly wonder if it's a mental problem.
Like if it's a mental
illness, I'm being honest,
like why is it reasonable
to not be rational?
I just don't understand
40s, 50 something genders.
Everybody can do whatever they wanna do.
Live, whatever life you wanna live.
They claim that the
police are the evil ones,
but then they don't
want you to have a rifle
or have a gun to protect yourself.
I mean, they wanna let criminals
go and bombard the city
and do whatever they wanna do.
But if you allow abiding
citizen, you should be punished.
They want you to wear a mask,
but then they allow people
to not social distance because
it's for the right cause.
These are people who are
illogical amongst us,
and it's destroying our country.
And these same mentally
adversed individuals
are the ones that have
socialism, communism,
that countries are destroyed over.
And it's not just a color,
it's a mentality because
there's black and white people
that are doing the same thing.
And there's black and white
people who are on the side
of saying, let's wake up to this man.
Let's stop hating each
other, let's stop division.
Let's stop lying about
racism in this country.
Let's stop talking about slavery
and talking about Jim Crow.
Let's start thinking
logically and working together
as brothers and sisters in
this country to make it better.
But these liberal people, I
don't know what it is, man,
I don't know if it's
just that they want power
more than they care about people.
And they're willing to say
and do whatever to get to that point.
- Honestly, I can tell
you what I think it is,
which I think most of
it's just lazy thinking.
They don't wanna think
about these issues hard.
So they think if they kind of feel
that something sorta, right,
they think that that makes it right.
I've seen so many examples of this
in the last couple of days
where you can get these people
to flip the positions that
they held three months ago.
There was a tweet that I
retweeted from somebody who said,
he's in an LA WhatsApp group,
like a community WhatsApp group.
And the woman who set up the
community was originally set up
so that they could get guns
out of their community.
And now she's in there
screaming in all caps,
"How can we get security guards with guns
to be watching our streets?"
And it's like, "Well, you
guys take whatever position
"you need to take on any given moment."
So when you call it
like a mental condition,
I mean, I always call it,
it's like a mind virus.
If they don't have a principled stand.
They just have, "Oh, I
feel like something."
And that's a scary place to be, right?
I mean, you can get people
to do almost anything.
- Yeah, I mean, the saying goes that
if you don't stand for something,
you'll fall for anything.
If you are living off
emotions, your emotions change,
and they become hypocritical.
And there are people in our
society that operate with facts.
I don't know if it's from birth.
I don't know if you're just
more susceptible to think
with facts and be logical.
I don't know what it is, Dave,
and I'm afraid that if
we don't start calling
this stuff out the good people
or the people who are strong minded,
we're gonna be overrun by these lunatics
because they are willing
to go all the way out.
And some of us who are rational
and logical, we're not.
I'm not willing to go out and protest
and burn down buildings
because I don't like
the COVID-19 response.
That's my last resort.
That's after I've gone to the legislator,
that's after I've
complained to the governor,
that's after I have been peaceful
for a significant amount of time,
I'm not willing to go and burn down places
and kill people over emotions.
And these are things that
I believe the strong man
has to stand up for.
And white people, and I don't wanna mean
to play identity politics,
but we need to start keeping it 100.
White people need to start
being bolder and more brave
and standing up against the lies
against the white
privilege, police brutality,
all white people are bad.
You're born with silver spoons.
You are oppressing a black man.
Listen, systematic oppression,
systematic injustice is clear racism.
Like how are you saying that every judge
is somehow racist against black people.
That is asinine to even
make a statement like that.
When you don't have any variables,
you cannot say that this
judge in this County
with this prosecutor, with this jury,
this jury pool convicted
a white man this way,
and then turned around and
convicted a black man this way.
They're not making a
one-to-one comparison.
They're talking about somebody in LA,
then they're talking
about somebody in Georgia
with total different laws,
total different judges,
different demographics,
different backgrounds,
different history, different mitigating,
and aggravating circumstances.
I just don't get it.
And I'm getting frustrated and upset
because we need to start standing up.
Just like Donald Trump, I'm
sick and tired of watching
the left seeing everybody to prison.
There's indictments
every time I turn around
for people on the right,
they're condemning them,
they call them a racist on TV,
but then you see Don Lemon
calling people like myself,
sellouts and Negroes, and
nothing happens with him.
You see Hillary Clinton
clearly breaking the law.
She should be in prison for what she did.
Nothing happens to them,
all of this investigation
of pizza and all kinds of other stuff,
and nothing happens to them.
It's because we just sit on the sidelines.
We're gonna have to start
stepping up and fighting back.
- So with that in mind then, and watching,
you're saying you're getting emails
from all sorts of people.
And I hear it all the time,
too that people are waking
up to this stuff and
it's hard to see, right?
It's like, you're watching a city burn
and it's like, "Oh man, are
there enough of these people
"who knows but we're laying the seeds."
When you heard the Biden comments
from a week or 10 days ago,
"You ain't black, if you
ain't voting for me."
Whatever the exact quote was.
In many ways, did that just
sort of sum up almost everything
that you've been fighting against
for these last couple of years?
- Yeah, I mean, he put
the icing on the cake.
(laughs) I don't know if
he realized that or not.
I don't even know where
he was at the time,
but I mean, that is exactly what I believe
the Democratic party
and the leftist ideology
that's how they feel about black people.
Like you can't think for
yourself, how dare you?
I can take away your ethnicity.
I can take away your value,
if you don't vote for me.
Although I've been in
office for 30 plus years
and I've done nothing for you,
but put black people behind bars,
bragging about the 94
Crime Bill, doing nothing.
These politicians have
done nothing on both sides,
"But if you don't vote
for me, you ain't black."
And he didn't just say you are not black.
Like he talks to white
people and other individuals,
he say, "You ain't black."
Like he's suggesting that all
black people are the same,
and that we're gonna
listen to your urban slang,
and we're gonna somehow fall in line.
The Democrats have been doing
this from the beginning.
They have never changed,
Jim Crow, slavery, the KKK,
it has never changed.
It went from a physical bondage
to a psychological bondage.
And there are people,
unfortunately, they fall for it
because there are people
that stood up for Joe Biden.
They defended Joe Biden,
and they said it was a joke.
They said all these other things.
And that is exactly what
individuals used to do
during the slave time,
where they had a good with the master.
And they felt like they
were doing really well.
And they wanted to hold
the other black people back
on the plantation.
They didn't want them to be free.
They didn't want them
to go out and explore.
And that's what these Democratic
talking heads are doing
to good faithed black people
who just want something
to change in their communities.
- Yeah, and by the way, it's
not just the talking heads
because I'm sure you've
seen the same tweets I have
from celebrities, black, white,
and every other color who are...
they're egging it on
while at the same time,
you know the Cardi B one,
she's basically egging this thing on.
And then somebody posted,
"It's like, she's got a
bowling alley in her house."
"I'm pretty sure she's gonna be okay.
"Pretty sure she's got a fence.
"Pretty sure she's got security guards."
And I wonder if they were
burning down her Whole Foods
where she probably sends her
employees to shop for her.
If maybe she'd have be singing
a different tune, you think?
Oh, you know they would,
these people are fake.
They're all disingenuous.
I mean, these people, I
don't know, like I'm saying,
I don't know if it's intentional
or these people are
having a mental breakdown.
I mean, Cardi B brags
about drugging people
and robbing people.
A lot of these celebrities
are celebrating criminals.
They're celebrating rappers
who spent their whole life
selling drugs, beating
people up, shooting people.
And they're celebrating
these very same people.
And then when a young
man like Tyshawn Lee,
people may not know who he is.
A young man in Chicago
who was nine years old,
got shot up by two thug gang members.
They put cigarette butts out on him.
When somebody like Tyshawn Lee passes away
or a nine year old getting killed
in a drive by shooting or a
young lady doing the schoolwork
gets shot through the window
because of knuckleheads
out there are killing people.
Where are these people?
Where are the celebrities?
Chicago had the worst weekend since 2015.
And I remember why they stopped at 2015
because before 2015, they had
82 shootings and 14 homicides.
And that's just one weekend.
Where are the celebrities?
Where is LeBron James?
Where's Colin Kaepernick.
He's not in Minnesota protesting.
He's not doing anything.
The only kneeing or kneeling
that Colin Kaepernick is doing
is probably the kneel down to
pick up his Louis Vuitton bag
that he didn't purchase
from that huge million dollar Nike deal.
These people are fake.
They don't have no integrity.
They have nothing.
They're just aimless,
almost soulless shells,
walking around virtue signaling.
- Do we have any other ideas
on how to keep breaking
the paradigm then?
I mean, you've been doing
an incredible job of it,
but anything else that
we can do besides facts
and being decent and trying
to be upstanding citizens
and the rest of it?
- Now, man, I think it
comes down to education.
It comes down to love.
Sometimes you got to do
some tough love in there,
but sometimes you do have to be empathetic
and you have to know your audience, man.
Like if you're talking
to a friend that you love
and that you care about
and y'all know each other,
then you can have a softer approach.
You can talk to them, send them videos
and send them encouragement,
and remain a loving, decent friend.
And then when you have people
who they don't care about you,
they hate you, you're Uncle
Tom sellout, a fool or racist.
Then you can hit them with the hard facts
and you can just keep pushing it
because everything starts
in here, everything.
Even I know there's people
that don't believe in God,
and there is a concept that
I believe that is reasonable
is the secret.
You know the book "The Secret."
- (Rubin laughs)
It starts up here.
I read it, yeah.
- You can manifest what
you become in your mind.
You can manifest your destiny,
and I think it's associated the Bible too
'cause the Bible talks about manifesting
and speaking life and death.
The power of life and
death is in your tongue,
but you can speak things into existence.
So if in your mind, you are
being told that the white man
is against you, racism
is destroying America.
You can't ever go here or
there without the white man,
the country is bad.
Your country will be bad to you.
You will begin to fulfill the prophecy
that you set in your mind.
But if you begin to hear the truth
and the truth is in your heart,
and you begin to understand
logic and reason,
and you hear the truth about America,
how America is the greatest
country on planet earth,
how America is the least racist place
you're gonna ever exist in
this dispensation of time,
how America gives you the opportunity
to become whatever you want.
You can start from zero
and become a billionaire.
When those things are
implemented in your mind,
perpetuated like great
human beings like you and I,
then people will begin to change.
An atmosphere will begin to be created
and we will see less of this
evilness, hatred, dysfunction.
And we'll see more people
coming out of this thing
being victorious and uniting
as an American front.
- I should let you go there
because it was a beautiful ending,
but I do have one more for you.
And I also wanna mention that everything
that you said there, you know
I spent a year and a half
on tour with Jordan Peterson.
And one of the things that he would push
almost every single night of the tour
was that if you just told the truth,
the amount of correction that
you could put into the world
would be unimaginable.
And I think that really is
what you're saying there.
So I do have one more for you though,
because I think this is
where a lot of people
that are maybe disaffected
lefties or confused liberals
or whatever that is, but they're waking up
and they're suddenly going,
"Oh, maybe the police
"can't protect me the way I thought."
Or all of the things that
we're all thinking right now.
I know you're also
a big Second Amendment advocate obviously.
Can you just talk a little
bit about how people
should not be afraid of guns
and maybe should be willing to take
a little more responsibility
for the security of themselves,
their property and their family?
Because I think that's the
next growing movement right now
is all the lefties who
thought they'd always be safe
in Beverly Hills, who
suddenly are watching it burn.
I mean, quite literally
right now and going,
"Oh, well maybe I do
have to protect myself."
- Yeah, I mean, this
is a free I don't know,
90 day trial to communism.
And it's also a 90 day trial
to a Second Amendment class.
I mean, if you just have
been existing in America,
you could have dropped off another planet.
You have come to America.
You're gonna realize that
socialism and communism
and the stuff that the left is pushing
is something that nobody wants.
And then you're also gonna realize
that you probably should carry
a firearm to defend yourself
because this is something that
I've been telling people for years.
As a former police officer,
I understand that cops cannot
be teleporting everywhere to save you.
We're at another call.
Somebody breaks in your house.
You have to then call 911
and you know the process,
it takes minutes.
And your life can be a
lost or saved in seconds.
People should stop all of
the believe in the media
and in AR-15s and a big boogeyman,
and start realizing what the
founding fathers were thinking
when they implemented
your Second Amendment.
And people should realize this as well.
Guns don't have to be a scary thing.
Go to a gun range, get your CCW license,
shoot at the firearms range
because you are getting a front row seat.
To, if you do nothing, and you
sit back with your hands up
and hope the God that the police
is gonna show up to your mansion,
you're gonna end up in a bad position.
You're gonna end up with your
hands up and your pants down.
And I don't want to live like that
and I don't want other people to,
so listen to people who are
logical like myself and others
who are telling you, and
been warning you for years,
go and get yourself personal
protection firearms.
If it's a shotgun, if it's
a handgun, if it's a AR,
I have all of them, get
those for your household
because it's not just the looters
that you have to worry about.
It's not just the criminals
You should have those protections
in case there's a problem
with foreign entities
coming into our country,
terrorism coming into our country.
All of those things, you
can assure your protection,
if you just adhere to
the Second Amendment.
- Brandon, I got to tell
you, everyone always asks me
when I get interviewed.
They say, "What's your
favorite type of guest?"
And I always, "It's so obvious to me.
"It's the type of people
that are clearly just doing
"what they're supposed to be doing."
I don't know that there's
a better example than you
because you are just doing what
you're supposed to be doing.
I know you've got a million things to do.
Thanks for joining us.
It's @OfficerTatum on Twitter,
and we'll tag in all that good stuff
and just keep it up, man please.
- Thanks Dave.
Thanks for having me on, man.
I love your brother and I see
you the next time (laughs)
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.